bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo compagne
mickaël zeze bonjour michael dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
cette semaine il y a les discours de
toulon de nicolas sarkozy révision du
traité européen convergence avec
l'allemagne sommet français pour
l'emploi en janvier
autant de pistes évoquées pour conjurer
la crise les socialistes ont trouvé
cette semaine leur angle d'attaqué
contre nicolas sarkozy l'accusent de
faire les déplacements aux allures de
campagne aux frais de la république
ils ont donc saisi la commission les
comptes de campagne sur la question
enfin les socialistes qui ont bien des
problèmes avec l'accord passé avec les
écologistes cette fois c'est un
paragraphe sur le droit de veto de la
france l onu qui plonge françois
hollande dans l'embarras le candidat
socialiste déclare qu'il n'appliquera
que les mesures les plus essentiels de
l'accord est notre invité cette semaine
et yannick jadot beaux jours yannick
jadot député européen ancien membre de
greenpeace ancien responsable de
greenpeace avant de rejoindre europe
écologie et les verts il ya encore une
dizaine de jours nous et y est le porte
parole de campagne d'eva joly
vous avez démissionné de votre fonction
visiblement vous n'étiez pas d'accord
avec la ligne politique d'eva joly
aujourd'hui vous avez rejoint l'équipe
de campagne mais plus porte parole alors
est-ce à dire que eva joly à une
nouvelle bonne ligne de conduite je
parle pas de ligne de conduite on peut
parler de ligne politique
je crois que pendant une période
effectivement où on était au coeur des
négociations avec le parti socialiste et
puis après la signature de cet accord
on a eu des différences de point de vue
eva joly et moi sur ce sur cet accord et
la façon dont cet accord servait ou pas
la campagne présidentielle d'eva joly
à partir du moment où vous retrouver
dans cette situation là en tant que
porte parole
vous considérez que vous n'êtes pas la
meilleure personne à ce poste pour
servir la candidate donc on s'est
expliqué avec eva joly on s'est expliqué
en réunion de campagne et j'ai mentionné
j'ai effectivement décidé prendre les
responsabilités
habilité de mettre en retrait de cette
fonction de porte parole
ces différences de ligne politique c'est
des gérants de l'analyse portait sur
quoi sur le fait que cet accord pouvait
être un formidable levier pour la
campagne présidentielle moi je pense que
cet accord à perdre l'accord ps et
l'accord ps et verts je pense que c'est
un bon accord
je pense qu'il a été très mal vendu au
sens de sa communication il a pas on a
eu beaucoup de confusion
il y en a l'impression que c'est
simplement un accord électoralistes je
pense que c'est un accord où nous avons
réinventé
je dirais la relation entre les
socialistes et les écologistes à la fois
ci un gros de ne pas soutenir plus que
ça cet accord j'en avais on avait une
différence d'analysé politique et cette
différence d'un analyste politique
elle peut parfaitement exister au sein
de l'équipe de campagne dans laquelle
j'aime retrouver dès lundi
mais en tant que porte parole ça ne
pouvait plus fonctionner vous vous
souvenez peut-être que eva joly avait
été un peu mise en porte à faux par
rapport à mes déclarations sur france
inter était pas question de renouveler
cette opération donc je moi j'ai
considéré que ma responsabilité était de
prendre du retrait pour ne pas mettre la
candidate portant mais membre du conseil
stratégique oui absolument ça a toujours
été ma ligne bien sûr on peut avoir des
débats sur cet accord il ya eu des
débats au sein d'europe écologie les
verts au sein des socialistes
mais ce que je trouve dommage c'est
qu'un moment où on invente une nouvelle
relation entre les socialistes et les
écologistes qui va quand même donné lieu
si la gauche et les écologistes gagnent
à une trentaine de députés
on en train de changer les institutions
vous avez bien vu les attaques très
frontal du candidat sarkozy de l'ump du
gouvernement sur cet accord c'est qu'il
ya bien dans cet accord des choses
importantes y compris du point de vue
des écologistes
on a ouvert un débat sur l'énergie
jamais revenir tu es dans ce pays et moi
j'ai considéré retard dans les
concessions mais yannick jadot je
voudrais vous entendre guy sur l'équipe
de campagne vous en avez parlé vous
étiez le porte parole il ya désormais
trois porte parole avec deux anciens
comme 4 avec deux anciens candidats à
l'élection présidentielle dominique
voynet josé bové ça fait pas un peu
armée mexicaine non je crois pas je
crois qu'on a enfin une équipe de
campagne jusqu'au diversité il ya
beaucoup de diversité je crois qu'on a
une équipe stratégique est réduite vous
avez parlé du conseil stratégique auquel
j'appartiens ces dix douze personnes qui
vont entourer la candidate pour la
conseiller sur la ligne politique
vous avez on a mis pas seulement des
têtes d'affiché mais sur les questions
thématiques les meilleures personnes à
ces postes de responsabilité thématiques
et puis vous avez une équipe de porte
parolat qui est expérimenté juste et qui
accompagnera la candidat un petit mot
qui de questions comme ça josé bové
n'est pas un peu électron libre pour un
porte parole mais ces raisons des
écologistes qui sont comme ça vous savez
si on a réussi rhdp cologie c'était
l'addition de nos différences et de nos
expertises de nos compétences de nos
parcours
il faut continuer dans cette voie là on
ne croit pas à la personnalisation du
pouvoir on ne croit pas à l'homme
providentiel voix ou non les pas d'une
seule voix et à la femme providentielle
on ne crois pas qu'on résoudra une crise
d'une telle ampleur
simplement parce qu'à un moment vous
avez au sommet quelqu'un qui voit la
lumière et qui décide de tout un jeu
n'auront pas forcément la candidate
providentiel non j'ai dit on ne croit
pas à la femme providentielle qui
résoudra tous les problèmes
eva joly est la bonne candidate pour les
écologistes
simplement il faut qu'on arrive à
exprimer dans dans la société
aujourd'hui dans le débat politique
la complexité de la crise et
l'importance de rassembler des
compétences différentes
alors vint l'occasion largement d'y
revenir pendant cette émission parce
qu'on va déjà commencer le lundi avec
cet accord qui décidément empoisonne le
parti socialiste
il y a eu la filière mox
voici le droit de veto français c'est un
petit paragraphe au sein de l'accord
signé par les socialistes et les
écologistes qui stipule que la france
fera des propositions pour la
suppression du droit de veto français à
l'onu alors une nouvelle fois voici
françois hollande contrat en ce lundi de
remonter au créneau
jean baptiste daoulas face aux
accusations d'irresponsabilité venues de
la majorité françois hollande a
immédiatement corrigé le tir ce matin
tant que je serai dans la situation
d'exercer la responsabilité de mon pays
si les français me là confie il n'y aura
pas de remise en cause du droit de veto
pas de remise en cause unilatérale du
droit de veto l'accord signé dans la
douleur il y a deux semaines entre le ps
et europe écologie prévoit pourtant la
création d'un siège européen unique l
onu et de militer pour la disparition à
terme du droit de veto il s'agit pour la
gauche de démocratiser l'institution
dans les prochaines décennies
mais le ps réclame d'abord une réforme
de l'union européenne il n'est pas
question qu au conseil de sécurité on
abandonne nous aujourd'hui ce droit de
veto
donc il n'y a pas ni politique étrangère
ni politique de défense au niveau
européen après la polémique sur le
nucléaire les alliés écologistes de
françois hollande calme le jeu les
précisions apportées aujourd'hui par le
socialiste ne sont pas contradictoires
avec l'accord entre les deux parties
françois hollande dit qu' il n'est pas
pour le retrait unilatéral d'une robe
veto de la france mais c'est pas en
effet il a raison c'est pas ce qui est
écrit dans l'accord monsieur guéant
essayer d'entraîner essayer de mettre un
coin entre entre nous sur cette question
tant mieux sa famille d'avoir des bas
mais c'était delà de la politique
politicienne
pas de nouvelles politiques pour
l'instant mais françois hollande a
prévenu ce matin il n'appliquera pas
l'ensemble de l'accord entre le ps et
europe ecologie les verts alors yannick
jadot député européen qui est
connaissait l'importance de la voix de
la france dans le concert des nations
est ce que c'est vraiment le moment
l'endroit dans un tel accord pour parler
d'un la fin d'un droit de veto français
je crois que c'est le moment surtout de
parler de ce qu'on veut pour l'europe
j'imagine qu'on va discuter aussi des de
sarkozy merkel et donc de l'avenir de
l'europe et de parler de la réforme des
nations unies je dirai ce que son se
satisfait du fonctionnement
de la gouvernance internationale à
travers le g20 qui fait des grandes
déclarations on s'auto congratule on
fait ça à cannes bientôt france à
hollywood mais on ne décide de rien on
le change un peu maladroite elle
attendait la question suivante à pied
alors dans parle même dans l'accord mais
vous savez pour être au parlement
européen
il y a quelques mois il ya eu un rapport
du parlement européen votée par les
députés ump au parlement européen qui
favorisait effectivement le siège
européen est à terme la suppression des
droits de veto au conseil de sécurité
pour quand même ce savoir que ces droits
de veto
c'est ce qui empêche aujourd'hui par
exemple d'intervenir plus efficacement
en syrie où ce qu'a pu être le cas pour
le soudan mais en irak en irak oui on a
posé notre droit de veto mais ça servait
à quoi on a en a mais la question encore
une fois n'est pas de faire taire la
france dont concert des nations
bien au contraire la question est de se
dire est ce que nos institutions
internationales aujourd'hui fonctionne
bien
non elle fourneaux fonctionnent pas bien
les réformes et donc il faut les
réformes et donc il faut aller vers une
politique étrangère une politique de
défense européenne et dans ce cadre-là
avoir une expression européenne beaucoup
plus forte dans le concert des nations
et à travers l'expression open
évidemment la voix de la france est ce
que dit ce texte cet accord c'est rien
de plus c'est rien de plus que ce qu'on
votait les députés ump au parlement
européen c'est la voie du bon sens pour
en revenir à l'accord est ce que les
socialistes ont vraiment lu ça fait deux
fois que françois hollande de la filière
mox et le droit de veto pour françois
hollande est obligé de monter au créneau
pour éteindre l'incendié
je trouve que les socialistes devraient
davantage défendre cet accord et
regarder ce qu'il ya dedans ne pas
simplement répondre aux attaques de
claude guéant ou d'autres membres de
l'ump ou du gouvernement
mais regardez cet accord et le défendre
encore une fois cet accord est porteur
d'une
dynamique très positive nous serons
rassemblés pour essayer de gagner les
élections de 2012
nous avons envie de changer la france
ensemble et vous savez comme moi à quel
point la france au mois de mai juin 2012
sera dans une situation absolument
dramatique et donc le fait d'être prêt à
gouverner ensemble d'avoir une majorité
parlement sentent parlementaire ensemble
est extrêmement important donc cet
accord n'empêche ni françois hollande de
défendre le projet socialiste ni eva
joly de défendre le projet écologiste
mais il nous inscrire dans une dynamique
nouvelle extrêmement positive et on doit
défendre cet accord pas parce que c'est
une plateforme écologistes en eau n'est
pas une mais parce que'il nous inscrire
dans une dynamique vous avez vous dû
l'écouter évidemment eva joly celle
semaine de nouveau revendiqué
l'indépendance du parti écologiste face
aux socialistes et à ceux qui pensaient
qu'elle pourrait se retirer et voici sa
réponse écouter écouter le match je
pense que dans cette campagne ce qui
compte c'est d'être serrée et c'est
d'être assez indifférent aux années à
mâcher je n'ai pas l'impression de
relancer ma campagne je n'ai pas eu
l'impression de l'arrêter je dirais que
je trace ma route et que je trace ses
trousses avec tout
tous les écologistes derrière moi et je
continuerai de le porter haut et fort
les valeurs pour lesquelles elle était
élue les valeurs écologistes alors
yannick jadot vous qui la connaissaient
vraiment très bien est ce que vous
pensez qu'à un moment donné elle s'est
dit je vais me retirer de la partie
non jamais ah non jamais alors ça il
peut y avoir des doutes exprimés par les
uns ou par les autres chez elle n'y en a
pas jeudi à l'ats cette détermination je
l'accompagnais du flottement dans
l'accord du bruit le premier jour de
cette aventure présidentielle et je peux
vous dire qu'elle ne doute pas une
seconde
deux à la fois sa capacité à mener le
combat pour les écologistes et cette
détermination à faire peser même si la
smart les eaux libres les sondages jours
puis sont à 5 6 4 ça dépend les sondages
sont les instituts vous avez vous savez
c'est assez étonnant
ce système vous avez a eu je crois 92
sondage sur eva joly vous en avais 12
kilomètres en dessous de 5% dont 11
provenant du même institut de sondage
donc ce que je dis mais voilà et puis
mais on au début de la campagne de ce
dialogue il s'est engagé avec les
français eva joly le porte
ce sera l'ensemble du mouvement
écologiste qui soutiendra eva joly et
qui portera dans la société
ces débats qu'on n'a jamais eue on a
vous savez ce débat sur le nucléaire
on n'a jamais eu en france aujourd'hui
on est à la caricature la plus absolue
venant du président de la république
venant de son ministre besson venant de
l'ump on va pouvoir enfin parler parce
que c'est le souci du président de la
république et c'est le souci des
français de politique industrielle
mais je trouve ça absolument formidable
une petite question si vous voulez bien
sûr sur eva joly on l'a vu à son point
presse 13 encadrés par noël mamère et
françois de rugy on lui souffle et
parfois quelques réponses
est ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui sous
surveillance mais non elle n'est pas
sous surveillance elle faisait un point
presse à la haye avait là des propos
beaucoup plus modérée à l'assemblée
nationale pour soutenir deux projets de
loi qui seront portés par des sénateurs
et par les écologistes à l'assemblée ou
au sénat
il est normal qu'elle soit entouré des
députés ou des sénateurs quand elles
seront six nations aussi on va en parle
donc donc ya pas d y a pas de souci vous
voyez bien qu'elle est déterminée et
qu'elle qu'elle ira jusqu'au bout
et puis on a on sera derrière et alors
cet accord toujours entre europe
ecologie les verts et le parti
socialiste provoque des remous jusqu'au
sénat les relations se tendent entre les
deux parties les sénateurs ps n'apprécie
que très modérément
le rapport de force a posé par leurs
alliés explications de fabrice culé le
sénat n'échappe pas à la règle
ici aussi les rapports entre le groupe
socialiste et les élus verts sont
parfois tendus alors les récentes
attaques contre françois hollande et
l'accord entre les deux parties ne passe
plus ça devient parfois un peu
la 100ème insupportable je dois dire que
ce comportement de donneurs de leçons
vous faites comme nous disons et c'est
bien vous faites autrement c'est mal ça
commençons à nous fatiguer celui qui
cristallise les critiques c'est
évidemment jean vincent placé
lundi encore le sénateur de l'essonne
demandé à françois hollande de rectifier
le tir
une nouvelle injonction pas du tout du
goût des sénateurs socialistes
je crois que ça fait partie du
personnage de toujours un peu faire
monter le ton pour essayer d'obtenir le
maximum je pense pas que ce soit le
moment et la bonne méthode d'un contexte
économique social
nous sommes aujourd'hui message entendu
et mis au point ce matin françois
rebsamen président du groupe socialiste
au sénat s'est entretenu avec le porte
parole des verts
ça y est donc les choses sont au clair
mais il faut il faut pas se laisser
aller à de tels propos je lui ai dit il
en est convenu donc on n'en parle plus
la page est tournée et on se concentre
sur nos propositions et notre opposition
à la politique de nicolas sarkozy
malgré cette confiance affichée beaucoup
de sénateurs socialistes se montraient
sceptiques
qualifiant jean vincent placé
d'ingérable alors vous qui connaissez
aussi très bien jean vincent placé
c'est un homme âgé ramener ce qu'il fait
du bien aux verts mais bien sûr qui fait
du bien aux écologistes qui ne serait
pas président il serais pas sénateur et
président du groupe europe ecologie les
verts au sénat je crois qu'il faut
maintenant encore une fois on a un
accord qui est intéressant positif qui
dit aux français les écologistes et les
socialistes seront prêts avant une
majorité parlementaire à battre nicolas
sarkozy
maintenant il faut arriver à faire vivre
nos différences de manière plus sereine
et surtout de manière plus constructive
ce qu'attendent les français c'est des
réponses à leurs difficultés c'est pas
qu'on se chicane entre nous ils
attendent des réponses et ils attendent
qu'on sorte la france du sarkozysme
faisons vivre mais je trouve qu'on a je
l ai dit tout à l'heure on a très mal
vendu cet accord les deux côtés des deux
côtés que du côté de côté d'un seul coup
on a l'impression que
du côté des écologistes et du côté des
socialistes on avait une sorte de patate
chaude qu'on voulait pas assumer alors
qu'encore une fois je veux dire ça a été
des mois de travail qui nous permettent
d'avancer
alors quand on a enlevé canton avec
martine aubry quand on invente une
relation émaillée des couacs mais
faisons attention à ce que ce bon
résultat ne soit pas mis aux oubliettes
il est positif constructif il permet de
faire vivre la campagne de françois
hollande qui est une campagne socialiste
françois hollande n'est pas écologiste
il socialiste eva joly n'est pas
socialiste et les écologistes
faisons vivre ces campagnes faisons
vivre nos différences mais surtout en
proposant des solutions aux français sur
l'industrie sur l'europe sur le chômage
sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est ça qu'attendent les français ils
attendent que nous gouvernons ensemble
en 2012 pour changer la france vous ne
croyez pas vraiment à la communication
des parcs sur des canes claqué la porte
un nom le rapport on le rappelle du
porte parolat mais vous croyez en
l'accord on a bien compris alors passer
l'actualité du mardi on va changer un
petit peu de sujets d'actualité se passe
du côté de l'ump qui tient une nouvelle
convention est le thème de cette
convention qui doit alimenter le projet
présidentiel
le vivre ensemble mais il a surtout été
question d'immigration et de délinquance
des mineurs
l'occasion pour jean françois copé
d'annoncer une proposition choc
sanctionner les mineurs délinquants dès
l'âge de 12 ans un projet qui prévoit de
changer le code pénal des mineurs
visiblement cela n'oubliez pas à toutes
les sensibilités de l'ump reportage
mario lefebvre un parti rassemblé c'est
l'image que veut donner l'ump et des
conventions nationales et des cadres du
parti de tous les courants à la tribune
et un discours ferme sur les thématiques
chères à la droite comme cette
intervention mardi soir de claude guéant
l'immigration nous souhaitons qu'elle
soit maîtrisé nous souhaitons qu'elle
soit maîtrisé pour que nos valeurs
soient respectées pour que nos lois
soient respectées pour que notre mode de
vie soit respectée mais quelques minutes
après ces mots à la belle unité
affichez se fissure par la voix de jean
pierre raffarin
bien sûr qu'il faut maîtriser
l'immigration mais celui des immigrés
qui respecte la règle il a le droit
aussi à notre considération ne faisons
pas des immigrés des adversaires globaux
et collectif
l'immigré qui respecte la règle c'est un
ami de la république
c'est un ami de la france l'immigration
fait débat au sein même du parti
mais pas seulement l'ump propose un code
pénal spécifique pour les mineurs et des
sanctions dès 12 ans nadine morano
christian estrosi n'en veulent pas jean
françois copé a tenté de minimiser ce
qu'il appelle des débats au sein du
parti
pas question de reconnaître la moindre
opposition interne aux propositions
sécuritaires mais l'unité officielle de
l'ump n'a pas résisté aux débats sur
l'immigration et la sécurité
yannick jadot le voit bien il ya des
dissensions au sein même de l'ump
concernant la délinquance des mineurs
vous est ce que vous seriez pour ce code
pénal pour les mineurs j'ai un mon plus
grand fils à 12 ans imaginez la cible
tomberait dans la cible je trouve ça
absolument effroyable
franchement je trouve ça absolument
effroyable qu'on puisse envisager de
sanctionner les enfants de 12 ans à ce
moment là j'ai un deuxième fils canal 9
pourquoi pas neuf ans pourquoi pas huit
ans je trouve que vous mentionnez les
divergences au sein de l'ump
quand je vois mes collègues
parlementaires européens du ppe 1 du
groupe qui raque qui réunit l'ump aussi
ils sont un peu inquiets ils sont un peu
inquiet de cette prise en otage de l'ump
par la droite populaire qui n'a de
populaire que le nom qui est une droite
populiste qui a pour perspective
l'alliance entre 2014 et 2017 avec le
front national a vouvoyé l'alliance avec
le front national à moi je crois très
clairement qui a un projet politique qui
est en 2014 d'avoir quelques élections
locales où il y aura des alliances avec
le front national si marine le pen si
évidemment sarkozy perd ce qui permettra
à la recomposition de la droite pour un
projet politique en 2017 je crois que
malheureusement jean francs
copé s'inscrit dans cette ligne et
beaucoup de parlementaires de la droite
beaucoup de gens qu'on rencontre sont un
peu effondré par cette prise de position
d'un an mais ils ne feront jamais
d'alliance et il ne s'y est des
alliances en 2014 localement elles
seront dénoncées mais ce sera quand même
à titre d'exemple pour voir si ça marche
faudra que marine le pen rentrer dans
une droite plus un petit peu plus
modérée mais il y à là je crois un
danger très fort pour la droite
républicaine de voir de plus en plus un
discours qui est anti jeunes qui est
anti immigrés qui est islamophobe et on
va voir dans cette campagne quand même
un projet qui malheureusement tel qu'il
se présente aujourd'hui notamment par la
voix de claude guéant par les discours
de buissons par malheureusement certains
propos du président de la république une
droite qui considère que la différence
dans notre société est un danger vous
avez sans doute vu cette une de
libération cette semaine qui a fait
beaucoup réagir et compris claude guéant
claude guéant la voix de le pen ça vous
semble un peu exagérée ou pas non je
n'ai pas la voix de le pen
malheureusement c'est la voie d'une
certaine droite aujourd'hui très
présente l ump qui encore une fois je
crois fait main basse sur l'ump en tout
cas en terme de communication politique
et claude guéant s'inscrit dans cette
logique ou pour gagner en 2012 il faut
diviser les français cette fois les plus
fragiles les plus fragiles donc les
populations immigrés sur sur l'islam sur
les jeunes sur les pauvres on voit bien
que c'était en 2007 ceux qui sont
responsables d'un tonneau explique ceux
qui sont responsables de la crise ce
sont ceux qui fraudent la sécu on est
sur un discours qui encore une fois tape
sur les plus faibles pour ne pas assumer
la responsabilité de ce gouvernement de
cette présidence depuis cinq ans pour
amener les voix dans son corps au
premier tour c'est parce qu'on avait en
2007 déjà
mais c'est juste rassembler son
rassembler son camp mais si vous
considérez que rassembler le camp de
l'ump s'y rassembler les voix du front
national
c'est une c'est une stratégie mais que
moi je conteste aux noms y compris
les valeurs d'une certaine droite
républicaine qui encore une fois
aujourd'hui ne s'y retrouve plus et
c'est très dangereux parce qu'on a
besoin aujourd'hui plus tôt de
réconcilier les français de leur
proposer des solutions plutôt que
d'échapper à la responsabilité de la
crise en tapant encore une fois sur les
plus faibles
mardi toujours le parti socialiste
s'attaque à nicolas sarkozy en cause les
déplacements du président de la creuse
au tricastin pas un voyage sans s'en
prendre directement à la gauche et à son
candidat françois hollande le ps a
décidé de saisir la commission des
comptes de campagne et de se pencher sur
cette question qui doit payer les
déplacements retour cette polémique avec
yoann rôle à la semaine dernière c'est
ce déplacement qui a mis le feu aux
poudres en pleine bisbille entre
socialistes et écologistes sur l'avenir
du nucléaire
la visite de nicolas sarkozy sur le site
du tricastin dans la drôme ponctuée de
formules assassines pour l'opposition
sortir du nucléaire c'est donc remettre
en cause l'industrie
ce sont des pans entiers de notre
industrie qui s'écroulerait en tant que
chef de l'état je ne peux pas l'accepter
nicolas sarkozy en campagne à la sphère
n'est pas une surprise mais pour les
socialistes jamais dans l'histoire de la
vème république un président n'avait à
ce point dérogé à son devoir de réserve
à quelques heures du retour du président
à toulon auquel 5000 personnes devraient
assister la contre-offensive des proches
de françois hollande est lancé quand on
organise un meeting est un meeting pour
l'essentiel constituées de militants ump
avec une parole qui est une parole
critique de son futur adversaire
nous sommes dans un campagne haineuse à
un meeting de campagne électorale
nicolas sarkozy est aujourd'hui
un président candidat est il encore
président il est surtout un candidat qui
se sert de la présidence car en théorie
les règles qui s'appliquent sont on ne
peut plus clair depuis 1995 chaque
dépense de campagne doit être
comptabilisée pour l'ensemble des
candidats et le budget de chacun est
plafonné à 22 millions d'euros en
faisant campagne sans être déclaré
nicolas sarkozy prendrait selon ses
opposants un avantage déloyal pour les
députés de la majorité
pas vraiment de quoi s'émouvoir a donc
il faut qu'ils restent cloîtrés à
l'elysée il a pu droit de sortir c'est
vrai qu'on peut ne pas se déplacer font
tellement de bêtises qu'on pourrait
novès pense qu'un président de la
république a le droit d'aller faire des
réunions nous présente la république
continue ce qu'il a fait depuis 2007 il
se déplace il va en province et il
exprime ses analyses sur la situation
d'une région d'un métier il est
parfaitement dans son rôle mais je le
répète il le fait depuis quatre ans les
socialistes daniel vaillant et pascal
terrasse ont officiellement demandé à la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne de se prononcer sur la
facturation des déplacements du
président une question qui pourrait
également être portée devant le conseil
constitutionnel
alors yannick jadot fausses polémiques
ou vrai problème finalement ses
déplacements je crois que c'est un vrai
problème
ça ne nous engage pas plus que ça à la
campagne présidentielle mais c'est un
vrai problème surtout que il ya déjà
quand même de lourdes suspicions sur
deux campagnes auxquelles on parti à
participer nicolas sarkozy celle de 95
sur les financements karachi enfin en
lien avec les rétrocommissions sur les
ventes d'armes
sur 2007 avec une série d' enveloppe
quand on est dans de telles suspicions
sur des campagnes électorales
je crois que en 2012 on doit s'assurer
de la sincérité et de l'équité en
matière politique à la fois sur le
financement public des campagnes comme
sur les temps de parole est là
clairement on a un nicolas sarkozy qui
tente de refaire le coup de 2007
il n'est pas comptable du bilan il est
simplement un candidat en campagne qui
va nous expliquer que tout ce qui est
arrivé dans les mois les années qui dans
laquelle il est gouverné
président de la république ou en 2007 il
avant il était au gouvernement ne
relèvent pas de sa responsabilité qu'il
est simplement là pour mener une
campagne je trouve assez étonnante la
remarque d'un des députés de l'ump je
suis si c'est debré ou le cas qui dit
finalement il fait ça depuis quatre ans
donc en fait on a un président de la
république a été élu pour faire campagne
pendant cinq ans jusqu'à la prochaine
élection je trouve c'est une
intervention étonnante
en fait tant qu'il n'est pas déclaré
qu'il n'a pas déclaré sa candidature il
n'est pas sur fond de campagne donc à ce
qu'il faut qu'ils se déclarent vite
maintenant non je crois que quelle que
soit sa déclaration il va évidemment
tenté d'utiliser jusqu'au bout son
statut de président de la république
pour pour faire campagne
je crois qu'après il faut qu'ils aient
notamment la lll avec les commissions
les institutions qui s'occupent de
l'équité en matière de campagne
électorale c'est à elle c'est à ces
institutions de prendre de poser un acte
qui est de dire le président de la
république quand il va au conseil
européen est évidemment le président de
la république quand il fait des meetings
comme ceux du tricastin ou de toulon
hélas comme candidat donc ça rentre dans
les frais de campagne
allez on va passer au mercredi quand les
verts se fâche aussi avec les
communistes
il y à l'assemblée un groupe gdr 26
députés communistes parti de gauche et
verts rassemblés pour bénéficier des
avantages d'un groupe mais en ce
mercredi les quatre députés verts décide
de claquer la porte
motif les députés du front de gauche ne
veulent pas leur laisser la présidence
mécontent d'une candidature ps verts en
seine-saint-denis sombre brouille
racontée par jérémy hartmann depuis juin
il faisait cause commune sur les bancs
de l'assemblée communistes et
écologistes côte à côte pour former un
groupe parlementaire
la gauche démocrate et républicaine une
alliance qui a pris fin hier le parti
communiste reproche aux écologistes
l'accord électoral qu'ils ont conclue
avec le ps au détriment du front de
gauche notamment dans une
circonscription de seine saint denis
c'est à la fois totalement déloyale et
une véritable agression puisque nous
considérons que
la chose qui doit guider l'ensemble des
élus de gauche quelle que soit leur
sensibilité
c'est gagner les circonscriptions sur la
droite et pas d'essayer de réduire un
groupe parlementaire en l'occurrence le
front de gauche la fin d'un mariage de
raison
communistes des écologistes s'étaient
partagé la présidence du groupe
le pc pendant la première moitié de la
mandature les verts pendant la seconde
en la personne d'yves cochet seulement
voilà le député parisien quitte son
mandat à l'assemblée nationale pour
rejoindre le parlement européen
mais les communistes refusent que lui
succède un autre écologiste françois de
rugy
tout ça a été cassé net par une volonté
hégémonique du parti communiste du parti
de gauche de vouloir reprendre la
présidence du groupe qui était pourtant
le symbole de ce pluralisme avec
seulement quatre députés à l'assemblée
les écologistes siègeront désormais
comme non inscrit
quand vous êtes non-inscrits vous n'avez
plus droit à des questions au
gouvernement sinon une par session vous
n'avez plus de droit déposé des motions
de procédure nous avons fait beaucoup
vous n'avez droit qu'à un quelque chose
qui est inaliénable à l'assemblée c'est
la seule chose qui nous reste à déposer
les amendements allaient défendre mais
cette situation sera de courte durée
la session parlementaire s'arrête fin
février pour les législatives de juin
prochain
europe ecologie les verts à l'assurance
d'obtenir un groupe d'au moins quinze
députés à l'assemblée grâce à l'accord
électoral conclu avec le ps alors les
verts n'appartiennent plus d'un groupe
mais comme l'a dit jérémie hoffmann dans
le sujet c'est pas un gros sacrifice
parce que la session se termine fin
février et qu'ils sont assurés d'avoir
un groupe grâce à l'accord vers ps dans
la session suivant dans la nouvelle
assemblée
c'est un très bon accord pour pour les
verts point de vue de sièges oui c'est
un bon d'accord je crois que il faut
assumer aussi cet accord électoral n'est
pas normal que dans notre système
démocratique
élection après élection malgré des
scores souvent au-dessus de 10%
on n'est pas de grands élus
à l'assemblée nationale et donc il faut
absolument aujourd'hui intégré cette
dose de proportionnelle
ça passe comme aujourd'hui on n'est pas
encore dans un système avec une dose de
proportionnelle ça passe par des accords
politiques avec les socialistes pour
cette fois et voilà on y arrive je dire
on doit peser dans la vie politique ce
sera un élément important un petit peu
piéger les socialistes gagnent et
pourquoi quand on voit les problèmes
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui dans leur
circonscription
quand on voit ce que ça peut faire à
l'assemblée ou au sénat monsieur à cincy
il est élu depuis 1981 dans sa
circonscription
nous avons un accord qui place un autre
candidat d'accord entre les socialistes
et les écologistes stéphane gatignon qui
est un jeune mère c'est un homme
politique qui est en devenir
il est normal qu'ils prennent toute sa
place je crois que monsieur à saint
ciers un monde aussi reconnaître que la
vie politique doit évoluer que le
personnel politique doit changer parce
que voulez vous dire quand même c'est
donc les verts ont obtenu beaucoup
en échange ils sont pas très
reconnaissants visa mans parce que
l'accord eva joly prend des distances
avec l'accord alors mais comme quand
françois hollande prend des distances je
dire vous on va on pèse très gagnant
dans cet accord dans les dernières
élections on a pesé plus de 10%
ok on va aujourd'hui si la gauche gagne
avoir peut-être 30 députés 30 députés
sur 577 on n'est pas encore à 10%
donc on est en train de changer on veut
peser dans la vie politique
ça me paraît totalement légitime oui
c'est un bon accord mais c'est un accord
aussi qui permettra à des socialistes
d'être élu et qui permettra j'espère à
une nouvelle majorité parlementaire de
vivre en 2012 et de changer la france
donc c'est un bon accord pour les
écologistes c'est un bon accord pour les
socialistes
donc ya pas de raison place de trouver
pour l'instant mais ils y viendront
peut-être mais à partir du moment où
forcément sur une circonscription
le candidat potentiel socialiste va être
remplacé par un candidat écologiste
il est normal qu'ils soient pas contents
jeudi on va pas se raconter d'histoires
mais la question c'est quand même un
scrutin national
notre objectif est de changer la france
est donc un moment on doit dépasser ces
mécontentements locaux et moi je trouve
que monsieur par exemple
delanoë devrait avoir davantage
confiance dont sanofi madame hidalgo
je trouve qu'en permanence taper sur
cécile duflot montre qu'il n'a pas
totalement confiance dans sa dauphine
je trouve ça dommage à l'avoir parlait
toujours de l'élection présidentielle
mercredi toujours françois bayrou
dévoile ses pistes pour redresser la
france une conférence de presse avant
son annonce officielle de candidature la
semaine prochaine vous allez l'entendre
d'or ce sujet de fleurs sauvages
le leader du modem ne refuse pas la main
tendue de françois hollande lancé un
petit peu plus tôt dans la semaine
c'était la foule des grands jours au
siège du modem ce matin le président du
mouvement démocrate a réuni la presse
pour présenter ses conditions pour
sortir la france de la crise l'occasion
pour françois bayrou de rappeler que
seul un gouvernement d'union nationale
pourra d'après lui redresser la
situation de la france les courants
principaux de droite républicaine
2 centre et de gauche réformiste
ces courants principaux ils ont à faire
ensemble alors je donne pas de nom parce
que ça serait provocateur mais vous
voyez bien que est en train de naître
dans le pays l'idée qui va bien falloir
faire quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais
fait jusqu'à maintenant
une idée qui chemine aussi chez le
candidat socialiste à la présidentielle
françois hollande s'est dit prêt lundi à
accueillir françois bayrou à ses côtés
s'il gagne l'élection
il ya un vrai besoin on le voit dans
différents pays européens de
gouvernement de large union 101 tessa
union nationale en tout cas de majorité
nouvelle qui prennent acte que il faut
les majorités extrêmement forte pour
faire des réformes structurelles
nécessaires à l'avenir aux mêmes lieux
de la vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens
d'après un sondage bv à 45 % des
français ne veulent ni de françois
hollande ni de nicolas sarkozy comme
président françois bayrou qui
officialisera sa troisième candidature à
la présidentielle la semaine prochaine
l'a déjà dit il ne fera pas d'alliance
avant le premier tour de l'élection
alors françois françois hollande qui
pratiquent la main tendue envers
françois bayrou est ce que c'est bon
pour vous cette idée mieux
gouvernement d'union nationale vous y
serez par exemple avec françois bayrou
quand on n'est pas la moins solide et on
est en train de germer oui mais parce
qu'ils se séparent sans devoir c'est ce
que françois bayrou propose pour la
france aujourd'hui moi j'en sais rien
les propositions économiques il a fait
des propositions l'europe jeudi ritable
surtout pour l'instant sur françois
hollande qui lui répond par la main
tendue tant mieux je suis dit ils ont
leurs jeux à eux c'est on les laisse
dans l'europe dans l'art histoire
ce qui est sûr c'est que il faudra plus
que 50 01 % des français pour changer la
france
est ce que ça sera avec le modem ou pas
j'en sais rien aujourd'hui encore une
fois il faut attendre de voir ce que
propose françois bayrou
comment il s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans
l'accord quelle est sa vision de
l'accord que nous avons passé avec les
socialistes sur l'industrie sur la
transformation écologique sur l'énergie
sur l'europe
moi j'attends de voir ce qu'ils
proposent après on verra si au soir du
premier tour
on a besoin aussi de françois bayrou
pour gagner ce qu'il y a un moment faut
pas se raconter l'histoire si on se
retrouve dans une situation où pour
battre nicolas sarkozy il faut françois
bayrou je pense que personne n'hésite
pas à aller chercher
françois bayrou pour battre nicolas
sarkozy mais vous vous le dites si
l'effet inverse on n'aura pas besoin de
françois bayrou alors que justement vous
disiez on n'est pas tous sont toutes les
gouvernés écologistes qui seules vont
décider de la commission s'est pas non
plus les socialistes qui décideront
seuls
on verra comment va se dérouler cette
campagne présidentielle on verra quelles
seront les propositions des différents
candidats
comment ils sont prêts à s'inscrire dans
un contrat parlementaires et dans un
contrat de gouvernement
et on verra sur cette base là qui
formera la coalition au soir proposera
une collision au sort du premier tour
elle aura passé au jeudi maintenant avec
le discours de toulon version 2
en 2008 à toulon déjà nicolas sarkozy
avait fustigé les excès du capitalisme
mondial au lendemain de la chute de
lehman brothers dans ce jeudi retour à
toulon pour faire le point sur les
pistes anti crise la solution pour
nicolas sarkozy passera d'abord et avant
tout par la convergence franco allemande
elisa bartholomé pour remettre la france
sur les rails plusieurs propositions et
une seule valeur le travail
d'ailleurs un sommet pour l'emploi sera
organisée dès le mois de janvier
nous ne gagnerons pas la bataille de
l'emploi sont les chefs d'entreprise et
sans les partenaires sociaux c'est
pourquoi en janvier prochain
j'inviterais tous les partenaires
sociaux à participer à un sommet sur
l'emploi pour que chacun puisse apporter
des solutions faire des propositions
mais favoriser l'emploi n'est pas tout
deuxième proposition la mise en place
d'une règle d'or européenne
le président de la république a de
nouveau insisté sur cet outil
budgétaires appelant à sa rapide mise en
place remettre l'europe au centre des
préoccupations telle est la troisième
proposition en lien avec angela merkel
nicolas sarkozy a suggéré la création
d'un nouveau traité pour une union
européenne renforcée
c'est pourquoi la france milite avec
l'allemagne pour un nouveau traité
européen refonte en ai repensé
l'organisation de l'ordre la chancelière
allemande est attendu lundi à paris
nicolas sarkozy et angela merkel ferons
ensemble des propositions pour garantir
l'avenir de l'europe
après les mots les actes nick shadow le
député européen vous êtes sûrement
suivait attentivement ce discours vous
en avez pensé quoi est ce que cette
convergence franco-allemande qui se
dessine vous semble une bonne piste
alors déjà j'étais très surpris qu'il
fasse un discours à toulon
parce que quand on est comptable de les
promesses qu'on des engagements qu'on a
pris c'est bizarre de retourner à un
endroit sachant qu'on n'a pas tenu ses
engagements
gerry predy fiscaux engagement non mais
attendez les laves annoncé la fin des
paradis fiscaux ils sont toujours là il
avait annoncé la moralisation de la
finance
elle est toujours là et elle fonctionne
toujours de la même façon et il avait
annoncé la version n'avait cessé c'est
quand même c'est quand même intéressant
encore une fois en tant que tactique
politique à d'effacer ça pour aller plus
haut oui mais on peut pas nicolas
sarkozy ne peut pas nous faire de
nouveau le coup de 2007 où ils étaient
pas comptable du bilan de jacques chirac
là c'est son propre bilan il peut pas
faire nicolas sarkozy candidat en
rupture totale avec nicolas sarkozy à la
présidence et le moteur franco allemand
est le moteur franco allemand
moi j'étais il ya quelques quelques
temps angela merkel disait par exemple
sur l'industrie l'allemagne sera le pays
pionnier dans le monde sur les énergies
renouvelables
il y a quelques mois barack obama disait
l'économie qui dominera le 21e siècle
c'est l'économie qui fera le choix des
économies propres et vous avez nicolas
sarkozy qui arrive avec charles de
gaulle une immense président
incontestablement le général mais qui ne
connaissait pas internet ne connaissait
pas le téléphone portable était dans
l'histoire du charbon est quand même en
2011 fait référence à charles de gaulle
pour donner une vision de l'ain
ce tri pour la france si quand même la
fpt la france du minitel
c'est la france du concorde il faut
quand même faire un peu attention et
donc le couple franco allemand
ses doit être aujourd'hui un couple qui
doit se repositionner dans l'europe
là le la contradiction fondamentale car
nicolas sarkozy est qu à angela merkel
aujourd'hui sur leurs discours sur
l'europe c'est qu'ils disent il faut
plus de responsabilités là dessus on est
d'accord
si on veut faire plus d'europe
mutualiser les dettes et qui est plus de
solidarité il faut plus de
responsabilités on en est d'accord mais
pas c'est uniquement et c'est ce qu'ils
proposent tous les deux par l'inter
gouvernementalité qui aujourd'hui se
résume au dialogue franco-allemand
ça veut dire oublier les autres pays
européens billets les autres pays
européens oublier toutes les autres
institutions européennes et être
aujourd'hui dans une impasse parce que
finalement ce que vous voudrez nicolas
sarkozy s'est renforcée par exemple plus
de pouvoirs à la bce pour que la bcge
ont commis des parquets ce que ne veut
pas donc on se retrouve dans une impasse
où finalement c'est angela merkel qui
décide qui est simplement plus
d'austérité et plus de contrôle sans
plus de solidarité sans plus de
perspectives en matière d'économie de
relance de l'économie
et ce en plus de démocratie et c'est
pour ça que le système ne tient pas
aujourd'hui souveraineté de la france
parce que vous le député européen il va
falloir que les budgets soient soumis à
bruxelles
vous êtes d'accord avec ça ou pas on
peut être d'accord sur l'idée c'est pas
une perte de souveraineté
aujourd'hui une europe fédérale ça
serait une taxe sur les transactions
financières un vrai budget européen ce
serait la fin de la concurrence fiscale
au niveau européen ce serait une
meilleure défense du modèle social
ça serait une meilleure défense d'un
modèle industriel donc c'est pas une
perte de souveraineté c'est comment
regagner grâce à l'europe de la
souveraineté notamment face aux marchés
mais à partir du moment où vous ne
mettez pas clairement sur la table par
exemple au conseil du 9 décembre
l'idée de réformer les traités d'avoir
un débat avec le parlement européen sur
la réforme de ces traités encore une
fois ça doit comporter de la
responsabilité face aux déficits
ça doit comporter de la solidarité donc
plus d'europe
mais ça doit surtout comporter une
perspective et de la démocratie
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
pas un commissaire européen qui doit
dire si le budget français est bon on
n'est pas bon ça doit être le parlement
européen qui contrôle la commission
ça doit être les parlements nationaux
qui contrôle les états si vous n'avez
pas cet équilibre entre responsabilité
et solidarité démocratie ça ne marchera
pas les pop les peuples se rencontrent
et vous aurez n'importe quel discours de
marine le pen à arnaud montebourg
traitant bientôt les réunions du conseil
européen comme de munich et je sais pas
lequel
sur l'échiquier politique commencera à
parler de l'allemagne et du troisième
reich
ce sera absolument affligeant voilà très
fort à ce qu'a dit arnaud montebourg qui
parle de la résurgence d'un nationalisme
allemand
je trouve ça affligeant beau nettement
je trouve que la gauche ne doit pas
tomber dans ce piège là on a un problème
avec l'allemagne la position de la
coalition menée par un angolais a merkel
ne va pas dans notre sens mais l'enjeu
n'est pas de taper à bras raccourcis sur
l'allemagne en faisant renaître des
fantasmes d'une allemagne agi monique et
potentiellement durs à l'égard de la
france
il faut surtout reconstruire de la
démocratie il faut sortir du couple
franco allemand
aujourd'hui qui est dans une impasse il
faut remettre le parlement européen les
parlements nationaux
et puis surtout faire une relance
européenne qui mènera de l'emploi du
pouvoir d'achat aux français
l'un des thèmes de campagne de 2012
merci beaucoup et yannick jadot
merci d'avoir été notre invité merci
aude on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
prochaine
même lieu même heure